it was such a boy Justin Flynn they do
my friend what's up man hey oh my god
we're doing it how how you doing have
you have you oh yeah have you gotten
over the defeat at the game journalism
hunger games over today yeah I'm pretty
sure i got over accounting all my money
in the back there i saw a collector hi
you doing the facts why is actually
hosting just a minute ago about to play
some mortal kombat x otherwise just
enjoying some pokemon and street fighter
and whatever so you're gonna go look at
something right now yeah i think when i
actually hope for the pokemon booth
again yeah go pokemon all day all
pokemon like right next door to you guys
as well wait i thought did you shave
haha nice nice i forgot lexi hey to take
care is carnage Aaron Oh is he alrighty
oh really is it all there is always
there with man always go carnage come on
come on yeah como el juice man oh man
what's up my boy John hey doing a man's
here to somebody good to see you hello
yes it's great to be here uh Denny wire
one of my heroes I just want to say
Holman dick I mean I did you hear about
this guy's a performance at the games
journalism Hunger Games earlier today I
didn't hear ademi know they crashed our
picks up yeah bro I let you down the
thing is I'm not going to blame me i'm
gonna blame Justin Flynn he I thought
because he plays video games all day
every day and that's all he does is a
loser ah that he'd be really good at
being a loser but he was cuz he lost did
that make sense sure why not he lost I
let the hold switch family switch team
down I let you down man we lost the
games journalism Hunger Games thing to
tweet surely the biggest games
journalism side of the ball the first
one the biggest one the one that matters
the most biggest what do you think that
sucks the most we lost IGN beyond Oh
beyond beyond acceptable no words
unacceptable
I'm speechless I'm speechless do what do
you what do you do here at the [ __ ]
Boothe helping these jokers out well
basically I host some segments we talked
some developers about their upcoming
games and ask them what we can expect
from those games and basically it's kind
of like a hype train that we're writing
daily here and uh I can't get enough of
it every time these guys asked me to
come back I am more than willing and
happy to be a part of it so and John
when when is the rebranding happening
then uh you don't see it you have to
look deep what side your heart what's it
like what's the mood around the twitch
world at the moment like in in in light
of the news of the Amazon acquisition
you know you guys are questioning
Amazon's ago all four days ago and so
it's still it's still coming it's still
happening right so we're still seeping
in you're sweating why do all right I'm
sweater asking me these hard questions
in your London what's going on man it's
good man everybody's happy I know no
more hot questions it's packs enjoy the
show we're gonna keep we're gonna keep
walking my pleasures ever sir I'll talk
to you later yeah wipe my brow early god
damn it all right let's keep walking
let's keep seeing one else we can find
here that's a practice all the badges
bumping into your buddy
you